and the deep oceans are what we call "carbon sinks,"
because they trap and hold excess carbon from the atmosphere,
and therefore help to delay global warming.
Sometimes these carcasses also wash up on beaches
and provide a meal to a number of predatory species on land.
The 200 years of whaling was clearly detrimental
and caused a reduction in the populations of whales
between 60 to 90 percent.
Clearly, the Save the Whales movement
was instrumental in preventing commercial whaling from going on,
but we need to revise this.
We need to address the more modern, pressing problems that these whales face
in our waters today.
Amongst other things, we need to stop them
from getting plowed down by container ships when they're in their feeding areas,
and stop them from getting entangled in fishing nets
as they float around in the ocean.
We also need to learn to contextualize our conservation messages,
so people really understand the true ecosystem value of these creatures.
So, let's save the whales again,
but this time, let's not just do it for their sake.
Let's also do it for ours.
Thank you.
(Applause)